les différents protagonistes sont
arrivés peu avant 14 heures ici au
tribunal de commerce de tours rue
edouard vaillant d'abord jean marc
ettori l'actuel président du tours
football club accompagné entre autres de
noureddine el ouardani l'entraîneur de
l'équipe première fidèle parmi les
fidèles omar da fonseca est arrivée une
dizaine de minutes plus tard avec son
fils et l'un de ses avocats mais où ils
sont les sérieux on peut dire que quand
vous vendez quelque chose si c'est
vraiment alléchant il ya là que pour
vous l'achetez hors des biens certain
temps le club il est dans une situation
complètement ruinée et je dis pas que je
suis le meilleur attention disons que
par des liens on le fait aux deux que je
viens ici à tour mes petits-enfants et
habitat jean une vraie mémoire une
reconnaissance j'ai une même une
citation des vies qui me permet de dire
que je suis plutôt landes dans l'étape à
des marines et transmettre dès vouloir
peut-être laissé quelque chose les deux
équipes ont présenté chacune leur tour
leurs projets aux juges du tribunal de
commerce dans la chambre du conseil
trois options sont maintenant sur la
table quant à l'avenir du tours football
club actuellement en redressement
judiciaire le plan de relance du
président actuel du tours fc jean-marc
ettori à la priorité car il est l'actuel
actionnaire de la sas paix et si son
projet retenu il devra éponger la dette
du club estimée à 5 millions d'euros les
da fonséca de leur côté sont soutenus
par la mairie et à travers elle une
société coopérative eux en revanche ne
prévoit pas d'éponger la dette du club
la troisième option la plus douloureuse
pour les supporters du tfc c'est la
liquidation judiciaire de la sas paix
tours football club la décision des
juges consulaires sera connu dans les
jours à venir